PROFESSOR: Solutions
can be organized.
One way to do it, it's
not the standard way,
is with plotting
n here and l here,
and you have 0,
1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3.
You have all this points.
Remember, every
point this allowed.
Every integer
combination is allowed.
All those are energy levels
of the hydrogen atom,
but now you can see that
this point, when both are 0,
corresponds to n equal to 1.
Because if n and l are
0, n is equal to 1,
and there's just one
solution with n equal to 1.
These two points here,
when l is equal to 1
and n equals 0, with n is
equal 1 and l equals 0,
represent the two possibilities
that realize n equals to 2.
n equals to 2 is realized by
having 1 and 0 or 1 and 0, two
values.
Similarly, there
are three things
with n equal to 3, four things--
my graph is not that
great-- with n equal to 4,
and more and more states.
So for each n you have that n
plus l is equal to n minus 1.
And l can never
exceed n minus 1,
and that's physically quite
something that people remember.
But also n cannot exceed n
minus 1 or 0, both are there,
limited by these quantities.
So if you have some n, you
will have l and n, for example,
for some quantum number n.
You will have l equals 0
and n would be n minus 1.
That would work out.
l plus n would be n minus
1, or 1 and n minus 2,
or all the things up
to n minus 1 and 0.
So they take turns.
They have to add
up to n minus 1.
So let's plot.
Let's actually, we can go here.
We don't have too much
more to say at this moment.
So let's have this.
We can do a little counting
that is interesting,
and I'll count the number
of states for a given n.
So for example, for n equals
to 1, what can we have?
We said, l equals 0, and
capital N is equal to 0 as well,
and that's one state
for n equals 2.
What can you have?
n equals to 2, you could have
l equals 1, or l equals 0.
So l equals 1, or l equals 0.
And how many states
do we have here?
Well, l equals 1 can have
m equals 1, 0, and minus 1.
Remember, the m values is
another label for states.
Those are different states.
So here, there are 3 states,
plus 1 state, 3 plus 1 states,
that's 4.
n equals 3 will have l
equals 2, l equals 1,
and l equals 0, which
is 5 states plus 3
states plus 1 state, which is
9 states, and that's 3 squared.
And 4 was actually 2 squared,
and if you go on to n
you will have n square states.
Something that perhaps
you could try to count,
and show that that's true.
So what are our quantum numbers
for the states of hydrogen?
Well, our quantum numbers
are, it's our choice,
but physically we
want to understand
them each intuitively.
So here we go.
One most important quantum
number, and its name says so,
is principle quantum number.
So the quantum
numbers of hydrogen,
and the first
important thing is n.
We definitely cannot
do away with n.
It fixes our energies.
And now we have a possibility.
We look at this and we
say, yeah well, I actually
I either need to determine
what is l or what is n.
So it doesn't even come close.
Physicists will not say, oh,
I want to describe the quantum
number by the degree of the
polynomial inside the solution.
No, physicists will say, I want
to use the angular momentum.
And certainly, if you
know l, and you know n,
you know capital N.
So capital N is a funny number.
It has to do with the degree
of the polynomial that shows up
in between this leading behavior
and that exponential behavior,
very interesting, but
not directly physical.
The l, however, is
directly associated
to an observable
angular momentum.
So to describe the
state that I have here,
if I give you n and l,
you can see that you
determine which state you are.
So the second quantum
number is going to be l,
and the third quantum
number is unavoidable.
It's the z component of
angular momentum, should be m.
That's also physical.
We should not skip it.
So these are our
quantum numbers,
and they fix capital N,
in case you're interested,
as n minus l plus 1, and
that's interesting information.
So let's recall our variables.
OK, a rho is here.
That's very nice.
So rho is 2 kappa
z over a naught r,
but now we know what kappa is.
Kappa is 1 over 2n.
So actually, the rho
variable is tailored
to the quantum numbers.
It's just Zr over n a naught,
where n is the principle
quantum number.
So back to the solution.
You see, we have
to recap quickly.
Psi nlm is equal to U of the
energy of the radial equation--
so n and l is sufficient
for that-- over r Ylm.
Or the U is the thing
that we had here, Ul,
and now it has an
energy into it.
So it's a rho to the l plus 1,
still r and rho up to numbers.
So this is like.
A rho, a Wnl if we wish,
of rho e to the minus rho,
and Ylm theta phi.
Well, let's write one more
equation, and then finish.
So just to give the
feeling of this solution,
what does that give you?
Rho to the l, a
polynomial of rho,
which is a polynomial
of degree n.
n, which is little n minus l
plus 1 times e to the minus rho
Ylm.
It's important for you to
see the whole solution.
This is the whole solution
of the hydrogen atom.
I'll write it in one more way.
A, a constant, because
this is similar.
Rho, well, rho is, in
terms of units, at least
has r over a naught to the l.
Here it is a polynomial in
r over a naught of degree.
Little n minus l plus
1, and this polynomial,
we could make a
whole study of it.
These are Laguerre polynomials.
We will not look into
them in this course.
You may do it in a
more advanced course.
It's interesting, but it's
better to just get an intuition
as to what's happening here.
There is an e to
the minus rho, which
is interesting to have fully.
So this is e to the
minus Zr over n a naught,
and there's a Ylm
of theta and phi.
So this is your whole solution
for the hydrogen atom.
We should write the simplest
one psi 1, 0, 0, n equals 1, l
equals 0, m equals 0,
spherically symmetric.
Here it is, 1 over pi a cube,
e to the minus r over a naught
For the KZ is equal to 1.
Ground state of hydrogen.